favorite me go oh appreciate oh whoa
that's a fancy meeting I love fancy
meets I was gonna say chicken but now I
feel like poor I'm Spencer I'm Emily and
we're meat lovers and what are we gonna
be doing today today we're gonna be
guessing what kind of meat were eating I
think Oh
Oh meats go into two categories red or
white those are the flavors of meat
there's no yeah I just love every once
in a while I crave a good steak yeah you
know mmm protein can get protein other
places but I prefer together than meats
here's the thing there's no quite
satisfaction like meat satisfaction all
right we don't know what we're gonna be
eating but let's get some meat
let's get that meat I'm really glad I
put makeup on me soon it's gonna be
smeared all over my face hit it up Wow I
actually can't breathe five six seven
eight
yeah where's the thing where is the
object that I am hating oh there it is
okay do I have it I think I have it oh
okay go
wait yo without my nose this is nuts
oh it's soft yeah I just did it oh you
ate it I don't hate it that's for sure
it's taste guy like a pulled pork
situation yeah it feels like stringy
yeah poor thing that's pulled pork
that's a pull pull pig let's go yeah I
feel like it got me it tastes like a
pulled pork pork meat meat meat meat
meat meat meat
why is it soft again you know I touched
it with the fork but it's soft I don't
want this kind of texture what is this
we wanted meat not like slop do I have
meat and buy for okay beat up on my bill
we wouldn't feel the same
oh it's wet turn oh I can't even taste
it what am i eating
oh gosh same texture for me shredded
chicken
yeah better check it sure chicken that's
chicken that's pulled chicken come on
are you going it again the last one I
thought was pulled pork and the texture
of this one feels super similar but then
once you're done kind of chewing it it
feels more like chicken yeah and I
already guess again we have the same
mind right now attack yes so we're just
in sync
yeah let's high-five did we get it yeah
it's pretty part tonight
I think it's Justin that's chicken it's
got the chicken texture I love chicken I
know by chicken this is chicken to be
exact
this is shredded chicken this is a
chicken boy I am a boy we are Platts all
day but you cannot see something where's
my fork I got it why is it soft
oh I got it alright okay is it another
pulled one yeah oh shoot oh wait I have
this on oh oh oh it's not as wet oh I
took a lot
this one tastes a lot like pork you're
right
oh okay um yo what if they all been pork
that's B don't know what Oh what is it
is there any other shredded meat that
we're missing here I'm like right beef
oh maybe the first or does beef in this
one Osborne yeah listen let's be that's
not beef that's beef fat not beef what
do you think it is it's too stringy to
be I think that was also pork I think
it's me but it was okay I'm gonna cut my
losses and say that this is pork that's
right I want to say well raagh on the
first yeah a middle one is chicken for
sure yes it's just I think it feels like
pork I don't think the first one was I
think okay last one pork I got silly
first one beef yes
middle one chicken yes chicken pork pork
chicken pork I think pork chicken beef
of sorts that's a cow there's no Pig
chicken cow I think we're together on
this yes we think please tell us
yes chicken pork yes all shredded yes
all with salt warning at them
the sauce was confusing you sauce them
all I thought I would get some pure meat
actually yeah oh my gosh
I still don't know wait chicken yeah
chicken beef pork yeah yeah I'm a meat
boy who's a meat girl oh my girl yes I'm
never doing that again no meaning that
was bad
first one was beef yeah that's upsetting
we were like yeah that's pork hey I only
got one wrong I don't the shredded
wasn't get was a was a great little
trick but you can't trick them well I
mean chicken II with my favorite so I
glad I got that one right
we started our day off with some protein
and I think that's a win
we got the leads we got the meats we got
to meet yeah we don't I didn't know I
could test this knowledge until this day
and it was a very fun yeah I never
thought I'd ever do this and now I did
it yeah and I feel good that I was
[Music]